♪♪
Bush:
Good morning.
How are you?
Ann Compton:
It was absolutely
spectacular weather.
Ann Compton:
Not humid,
skies were clearer,
TV reporter:
Smoke is billowing out of the
building...
AP Network News,
News Reporter:
A plane apparently has crashed
into the World Trade Center in New York.
We went from a very calm
beautiful day to one in which
our world changed dramatically.
♪♪
Narrator:
September 11th, 2001 was the
worst terrorist attack in U.S. history.
Narrator:
Now experience the first twelve
hours surrounding the events.
Narrator:
In a way the world has never
seen.
♪♪
Bush:
Andy Card comes up behind me and
says, "America's under attack."
And I'm watching a child read.
Eddie Marinzel:
We needed to move the president
and get him out of there.
He could be a sitting duck.
♪♪
There was a call that said
"Angel's next."
Angel is the code word for Air
Force One.
We worried someone in the
president's circle could try to
take down Air Force One.
Every plane had become a
missile.
One of the targets might well be
The White House.
Air traffic control:
All aircraft land as soon as
possible.
Bush:
Mother got on the phone.
She said, we're outside
Milwaukee.
Bush:
I said, you gotta be kidding me.
What are you doing there?
She said, you grounded our
plane.
Narrator:
In their own words.
She told me her plane had been
hijacked.
Theodore Olson:
And the line went dead.
(Choked up)
That really hit home.
Narrator:
Those at the heart of power on
that unforgettable day.
Condoleezza:
We did everything we knew to do,
but 3,000 people died on your
watch.
It just gnaws at you.
Narrator:
Come together to reveal what
happened behind closed doors.
Karl Rove:
She took the badge from her
son's dead body,
gave it to the president and
said, "I...I want you to always
remember".
I remember the Secret Service
screaming, take of your heels
and run!
We never had a crisis quite like
this.
Colin Powell:
Of course we all were hurting.
We all were terrified.
Bush:
The first plane was an accident.
The second one was an attack.
Bush:
And the third one was a
declaration of war.